[Music]
I want to talk about something you talk
about a lot okay and I want to come up
with a new framework and this is going
to get kind of nerdy and that's okay
good cool it's okay yes all right I want
to talk about comparison okay and here's
where I want to kind of unpack it and so
I'm going to talk too much but you're
the comparison Guru and I've been trying
to like dig into the nerd stuff of
comparison
yes and here's where I've come up with
and so I want by the time we get done
going back and forth I want to land on a
new framework about comparison okay so
we have Teddy Roosevelt Mark Twain Dr
Cummings whoever you say it comparison
the thief of Joy the death of Joy all
that so I've WR written this down so if
you're watching this on YouTube I'm
reading some of this I just want to make
sure I get this right there's a lot of
scientific literature tons about how
comparison social comparison is the nerd
word is actually wired into US
comparison is a feature of being an
animal not a problem not a bug mhm we
have such an innate need for connection
that we're designed to always be looking
for where we stand Rank and compare
always be doing this all the time
because if our tribe leaves us we're
dead right so wired into US is this idea
of am I over here am I over here where
do I stand I'm short I'm tall I'm big
I'm strong what's my role what am I
supposed to be doing so I started to ask
myself if comparison is part of us wired
into us as a feature not a bug in the
system
I also look around and comparison is a
thief of Joy it destroys us right and so
I'm trying to navigate both of them it's
an an innate part of us yeah and in this
current world we live in it kills us it
destroys our marriages it destroys
everything right and
so you've talked to moms for years
you've talked to men and women for years
you've been having this conversation
about comparison comparison
comparison if I tell if I lay both of
those down that it's a part of us it's
it's how we're wired it's how we're
built and designed and yet it kills us
how does that hit you does that hit you
as right or does that H you as where
think where we get off because I think
comparison is the V I think it's the
thing that we it's the it's the car we
jump in to ride but when we start to
turn on the jealousy routes and the Envy
routes I wrote Envy down yeah did down
so that's that's that's the actual thing
that I think destroys us I think
comparison is the thing we get in that
leads us there but like yeah comparing
you know um two you know my sweater and
her sweater it's like oh mine's cable
knit hers is okay C okay yeah yeah
that's cool that's cool that's great I I
made a comparison a literal comparison
but then suddenly when I want what she
has and I don't have it so now I want to
get it that's envy and jealousy and
that's the world that I think takes over
that b that's the problem I think so
comparison in and of itself may not be
the demon it's Envy I think so because
you can't have Envy without comparison
right I think it start a starting line
is comparison comparison right right
right yeah I don't think you just jump
to um
you oh I want that there's a level of
like oh my gosh well especially when
it's a person right because you're
comparing with another person another
human being they have something and I
want it whether it's the marriage the
lifestyle the whatever like and again I
think there can be a oh I want that and
I'm still good with myself
and maybe that's something I strive for
that's a fun job I would love to do that
one day right like there's like that's
not that's not jealousy all right the
last one is and you wrote an amazing
book about it let me grab it an amazing
book sweet little book look at that
sweet book so my wife is a children's
literature efficient AO right and her I
I don't fully understand how smart she
is but I know that she taught teachers
how to teach kids how to read She's Like
A literacy person and she's a huge
proponent of children 's literature and
how pictures are reading and turning the
pages is actually technology and it's
it's a it's a path for kids neural
connections to begin to to develop right
so you can read a book like
this and you can read a book like this
when you're a a young one right and
there's some really clear scientific
literature that says you want to set
your kids apart over an arc of their
life read to them when they're young so
when you said hey I'm putting out
children's book I was super excited
about it and then of course this is just
so magical and beautiful a lot of this
it's called I'm glad for what I have but
you talk about what I think is the
antidote for Envy the antidote for all
of this is gratitude being grateful what
you got y right and not not being
ambitious not having dreams for the
future but being able to stay right now
and contentment I'm so blessed
contentment so tell talk to me about
contentment there's like a sense of just
peace that we're okay like we can have
nice stuff we don't have to have nice
stuff like regardless of what's going on
around us there's just this level of
where we are settled we're going to find
happiness and joy and that it's kind of
what we were talking about earlier but
that's I mean for me that's what it is
it's a choice yeah and the stuff may
come and go but regardless of that is
beyond it's beyond that is how are you
feeling what's your sa of your heart
like where are you at so would you agree
that that's something you
practice yes oh I think so it's like a
skill and gratitude I think is part of
that right I think being grateful for
what you have leads into that
contentment um
but it's a Cho I'm like but there's a
level of like I have to I have to choose
this and sometimes it comes easier than
others and I feel like that's the fun
part when it does become like oh no okay
we're good like they're they're over
here doing this X Y andz or the new
Suburban pulls in but I got my minivan
I'm good I'm good you can go over there
and be like this car is amazing yeah be
excited for people oh sure and that
doesn't mean you hate your car no and
you can go home and be like I want to
have that Suburban one day cool let's
put the work in let's figure out what
that would look like right sure our
marriage isn't going to change if we
have that suburb just know right right
right it's good but yeah so the kid book
I was excited about it cuz I have yeah
four six and 8-year-old at home and yeah
like bedtime stories it's a thing and I
always love the books that have like a a
message at the end that I'm like as a
parent I'm like oh that was so good to
hear so I wanted that I wanted it to be
short I wanted it to rhyme I wanted to
have so I had this like whole dream and
contentment yeah is um for me a huge
message for my kids cuz I'm a natural
spend or I'm the one that can be the
like oh my gosh I'm going to accumulate
cuz it's fun and I love it um and my
kids started to be like where's the
Amazon guy like you know like they start
asking questions I was like oh no oh no
I've turned them into me so I wanted a
book just to walk them through the story
of like hey you want new toys you want
all of this stuff and it's not right or
wrong right there's not like a moral
compass to this stuff but at the end of
the day can we understand that the stuff
is not the thing that's going to fulfill
us and so that was yeah that was the
message I wanted to to put in and um
yeah and there's a spiritual element at
the end of God and we talked about this
but having a higher power choosing to
look Beyond yourself and attaching
yourself to something else besides just
you is really healthy so for me it's God
and it's in the book but for other
people maybe something else which is
fine but that's another big thing that
I'm like when we become our own Gods
like that's when it life gets messy I
think you've talked about this a lot
which I think is so I think it was us
when I was hearing it I was like that is
so right that's it like that's that's so
right I like to think of it like when
the more I stare at my own belly button
I can only go in a spiral I can only go
in a in a quick spinning spiral it's
when I pick my head up and beyond that
picking my head up I also I mean my my
hands are coming up right now if you're
if you're not watching this but it's
this sense
of I don't control anything I don't
control anything and I'm going to be
grateful for where I got put and because
I happen to live in this little sliver
of history have an opportunity to maybe
earn some more money or maybe um I can
do some neat things professionally or
whatever but I'm going be grateful for
what I got and yes comparison is wired
to me I'm going to look to my right and
my left and make sure I'm treating my
wife right make sure I'm my kids are
healthy and somewhat developmentally
appropriate but I'm also not going to
just walk around envious of I wish I had
that and I can't believe they have that
they don't deserve that yes I'm not
going to live like that I'm going to
choose to open my hands up and look up
and say thank you and please give me uh
give me some rain tomorrow right yep yep
and it just my whole body just even
saying that a lot my body just goes
right it's like restful yes like peace
that totally cool well thanks for coming
to hang out I know for having me on
appreciate it and for those of you
watching this conversation we just have
all the time it's just you all get to
hear it so cool I know so appreciate you
you're awesome
cheers